if you look at the progress in space in
1969 we were able to send somebody to
the Moon 1969 then we had this the Space
Shuttle that the space shuttle could
only take people to low earth orbit then
the space shuttle retired and the United
States could take no one to orbit so
that's the trend the trend is like down
to nothing people are mistaken when they
think that technology just automatically
improves it does not automatically
improve it it only improves if a lot of
people work very hard to make it better
and actually it it will I think it by
itself degrade actually you look at
Great civilizations like ancient Egypt
and they were able to make the pmids and
they forgot how to do that and the
Romans they built these incredible
aqueducts they forgot how to do
[Music]
it